as for Marvel and Creed star Jonathan
Majors there's more Fallout with news
that additional alleged victims are
coming forward variety reports multiple
women are cooperating with the Manhattan
D.A I'm coming for everything you
threatening me
Jonathan's attorney maintains his
innocence and today gave E.T security
camera and police body cam images which
they say are from the night of the
original incident and exonerate him if
you'll recall just over three weeks ago
a 30 year old woman believed to be
Jonathan's girlfriend claimed he struck
her in the face with an open hand
grabbed her hard enough to cause
bruising and placed his hand on her neck
so how could these images prove the
Stars not guilty well his lawyer says
seeing her drinking at a nightclub hours
after the incident and later using the
finger she says he broke to get up to
his hotel room is proof Marvel come
through
the alleged victim has also now been
identified as a woman who worked on
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania I will
take my revenge from those who banished
me and I will burn them out of time both
Disney and Marvel wouldn't comment on
Jonathan's future with the franchise a
court hearing is scheduled for May 8th
but his career appears to be in free
fall one after the other after to the
other his U.S army ads have been pulled
the Texas Rangers just dropped him from
their ad Campaign which was set to
launch tomorrow his appearance at the
upcoming Met Gala canceled both his
management and PR teams have reportedly
quit and as for starring in the Dennis
Rodman biopic in the works ET has
learned the studio Lionsgate is watching
the news developments closely
I'm Coming For You meanwhile Alec
Baldwin's involuntary manslaughter
charge has reportedly been dropped his
lawyers telling E.T quote we are pleased
with the decision this comes as rust
when back into production today a year
and a half after Helena Hutchins was
shot and killed on set
that's Alec kissing wife ilaria with
their daughter in New York just 24 hours
before heading to Yellowstone film Ranch
in Montana where principal photography
resumed the film's attorney telling E.T
quote the production will continue to
Bar any use of working weapons in any
form of ammunition
[Music]